well amazingly there appear to be
growing connections between viagra and
treatment for the coronavirus a nurse in
the uk just woke up from a 28 day coma
after she got a big dose of viagra
probably her first
one healthcare company is providing
chronovirus tests along with their ed
medication who thought viagra would save
us from the pandemic dr mark segal might
have predicted it he's our fox news
medical insurance man we go to he joins
us tonight to explain doctor
tucker we've been talking about viagra
we talked about it last week about
alzheimer's and we're doing further
investigations on it now as you said
monica almeida 37 years old she was 72
hours away from having her respirator
turned off they gave her a massive dose
of viagra and she woke up now what might
the connection be there well i started
looking into that a study just published
out of chile in a journal called
critical care found that this patient
study did not go on the respirator who
got viagra and they actually went out of
the hospital sooner now why would that
be viagra is not just used for what you
think it's used for it also treats lung
problems it improves blood flow to the
lungs it improves oxygen in the lungs it
treats pulmonary hypertension it treats
altitude sickness it makes something
called nitric oxide now nitric oxide is
something that the covid virus
decreases and viagra increases and not
only was there the study out of chile
tucker but there was
several studies around the world that if
you inhaled that nitric oxide your lungs
did a lot better with covid japan china
scandinavia all had studies like this
showing a big improvement with nitric
oxide just what viagra does so i think
this is the beginning of something and
further studies are going on and i think
this this is a potential treatment and
then you mentioned along comes a company
called roman and the new york times of
all places wrote this up the other day
and said roman which is a company that
actually you can prescribe viagra over a
telemedicine is now giving home covet
tests home covert tests you can't get
them anywhere but you can get them via
telemedicine via this company roman and
guess what you can get with a home test
you can get viagra so i have only one
question and i'm going to call roman to
find out tucker which do you take first
the viagra or do you do the home test i
don't know
i think i know well as you said if you
take it i'm quoting a massive dose of
viagra you wake up so i think it's
pretty obvious
is there anything that doesn't cure dr
mark segal
great to see you
thank you
thank you i'm getting ready to try it
out thanks tucker hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else